Wait, aren't you going to bed yet, Mise-
san? It's still early in the night, and I want to study hard for the two of us, so I see. I
don't feel like resting.  I won't
listen to you. Please stay still. It feels
hot.
If you have a fever, you have a body temperature, so
what's the meaning of your forehead?
Excuse me. Cover me with a blanket and keep warm.
Yes, some energy drinks and cold medicine.  I can drink all of it. I'll
call my part-time job to take the day off tomorrow. Well, I'll take it. I'm sorry, but
the manager is sweet. Did you know that I'll be angry if you don't take care of your body? To be
honest, I'll be
angry at everyone.  What I'm
saying is, it's nice to be able to talk to
her.My wife was kind and reserved, so I'm
sure she wouldn't have been so angry with me when I met her, so
I'm glad that our relationship has deepened.
Se-san is so
cute. What are you talking about? I'm already angry, so
please don't make fun of me. But I'm
happy. You keep
saying things like that until you're already sick. You're a
pervert who likes erotic cosplay. I'm sorry, but
if you act like a nice girl, I'll come any time.  I
have no choice but to be a good girl
DET